la première chose à faire bien sûr c'est
d'ouvrir le dessus de la cheminée voilà
ici ce qu'on voit c'est le tuyau qui
permet de faire rentrer l'eau à
l'intérieur de la cabane et c'est
branché directement sur la boîte de
flotte il faut que je règle le ça pour
que j'ai ici à peu près un pouce et demi
donc on n'a pas besoin de d'ajouter ou
de fermer ça c'est en continu ça c'est
une plaine dans laquelle il y a
plusieurs plis donc toc toc toc toc toc
toc donc ça veut dire qu'on a une très
grande surface et ça augmente
l'évaporation facilement par deux trois
fois donc c'est beaucoup plus efficace
[Musique]
ça bout à gros bouillon là c'est
spectaculaire
une fois que l'eau a fini de dévaporer
ici à l'antre dans la panne de finition
c'est vraiment une question d'équilibre
et pour avoir du sirop il faut que ça
brouille à peu près à 104 et donc
ensuite ça fait ce chemin là et puis
ensuite il reste qu'à mettre en pot et
le sirop est prêt
[Musique]
tout ce que je fais actuellement dans
mon Arabia me vient de savoir de mon
père c'est sûr que toutes les
connaissances que les gens utilisaient
c'était tout des connaissances
traditionnelles mon père me disait tout
le temps quand le vent le vent vient du
nord ça coule pas mais là on a un
appareil qu'on a mis dans un champ qui
mesure la direction des vents et ça on
l'a depuis trois ans donc il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de connaissances comme
ça et qu'on doit vérifier
[Musique]
bah écoute mes premiers souvenirs de du
temps des sucres j'avais trois ou quatre
ans et puis on allait aller à Billère de
mon grand-père Emile et puis je me
souviens que c'était des moments où
toute la famille se réunissaient on
partait avec l'énorme cheval mon
grand-père avait un Percheron ce
cheval-là me faisait une peur bleue
parce que c'était gros comme un éléphant
et puis quand j'étais un peu plus vieux
adolescent ma job c'était de corder le
bois devant l'évaporateurs pour moi
c'est des souvenirs qui sont très
extrêmement précieux et puis lorsque on
a acheté le terrain ici à shuffle puis
qu'on a remarqué qu'il y avait tous ces
beaux érables l'idée de moi-même
commencer à produire mon propre sirop
est arrivé et bien j'ai quatre petits
enfants deux filles de mon garçon et
deux garçons de ma fille donc ça me fait
quatre petits qui sont entre maintenant
entre 12 et 23 ans c'est mes clients
principaux avec eux que ma modeste
production peut s'écouler mais quand ils
viennent c'est vraiment le bonheur c'est
le bonheur de courir les érables une
journée comme aujourd'hui dans le beau
temps de s'amuser d'avoir la surprise
une chaudière qui est plaie une autre
qui est pas pleine etc donc ce bonheur
là d'être à la cabane à sucre
[Musique]
j'ai deux petits enfants une troisième
qui est en route je dis souvent à la
blague que une des raisons pour
lesquelles on a des enfants c'est pour
éventuellement avoir des petits-enfants
parce que c'est que du bonheur la plus
vieille Charlie a 11 ans elle vient
régulièrement passer du temps chez moi
la montagne durant les vacances d'été
durant l'hiver et ainsi de suite c'est
devenu une tradition aussi avec mes
enfants qui viennent au temps des sucres
avec les petits enfants et puis on
s'arrange pour faire une bonne bouffe et
puis passer du temps agréable ensemble
donc c'est tout ça qui est relié à cette
époque de l'année où on fait notre sirop
d'érable
mon grand-père s'il existait encore s'il
pouvait venir ici ou même mon père il
serait tout à fait étonné parce que il y
a quelque chose de magique dans sirop
d'érable entre cette eau qui goûte un
petit peu le sucre qu'on ramasse
patiemment qu'on fait bouillir et dont
on va mettre le produit sur les crêpes
ou sur les gaufres c'est quelque chose
de merveilleux qu'on n'a pas en Europe
qu'on n'a pas mis à peu près nulle part
au monde
merci beaucoup ça va que ma fille vient
de Californie à cause du temps d'études
pas pour venir voir son père pour le
temps des sucres les deux
j'ai pas encore de petits enfants on me
dit que ça s'en vient et je développe
très facilement en rapport avec les
petits enfants donc j'ai très très hâte
il y a vraiment aucun moyen de prédire
le moment où ça coulera la prédiction du
début des sucs c'est une science très
imparfaite ça varie énormément d'une
année un autre dans notre région on sait
jamais avant le 17 17 mars
des fois c'est le cas ou des fois c'est
le 22 ça c'est ma blonde ça c'est ça
c'est Julie Julie me dit un moment donné
fin février début mars moi j'irai en
tailleur fin de semaine ça va couler au
cours des prochains jours puis à date
elle ne s'est jamais trompée
au printemps les voisins alors les
voisins aussi
sont là comment ça coule il y a un côté
très très sympathique de voisins de
as-tu fait du sirop combien de temps
elle fait donc c'est très marrant puis
c'est très très très artisanal
c'est une intersection que je trouve
vraiment belle parce que là il fait
chaud il faut pas quelle température il
fait mais on est bien on est vraiment
bien puis dans le bois il y a pas de
vent il y a quelque chose c'est quelque
chose de très très beau vraiment
là ce qui est chouette c'est le bruit
c'est comme un concert il y a deux notes
différentes ils sont exactement au même
rythme en bas il y a la petite rivière
qui coule
si on n'avait pas les érables qui nous
force comme humain à venir en forêt au
printemps ça serait probablement la
période de l'année où j'aurai le moins
tendance à aller en forêt
quand on a fini de ramasser le DM je
m'assois ici souvent je veux écouter
puis là j'entends tous les nouveaux
oiseaux qui arrivent c'est presque à
tous les jours un nouveau bruit qui
produit on commence à voir les insectes
je pense que le fait de vivre dans un
milieu où on a cette saison là de
renaissance
c'est ça l'enseignement que ça nous dit
c'est que de l'espoir puis malgré le
fait que peut-être des périodes plus
sombres les choses vont s'améliorer des
choses vont renaître pour moi c'est la
plus belle saison ça me rend très très
heureux c'est clair que on s'en va pas
dans la bonne direction en termes de de
prévenir les changements climatiques en
termes de se prémunir puis de préparer
l'environnement bâti les infrastructures
ce qui s'en vient en termes de
production de sirop d'érable c'est sûr
que les changements climatiques c'est
une une inconnue parce que ça pourrait
faciliter la production de sirop mais je
pense que de toute façon on peut
s'entendre que pour l'ensemble de la
planète et de la population ce qui s'en
vient n'est pas positif
moi ce que j'observe c'est que de plus
en plus de variations à chaque année et
je pense que c'est en lien avec les
changements climatiques mais c'est pas
un réchauffement continuel c'est une
variation qui augmente une fluctuation
l'impression que j'ai c'est que les
hivers étaient plus rudes il y a 50 ans
qu'aujourd'hui mais faut faire très très
attention faut vraiment se méfier des
impressions faut regarder les temples
les moyennes de température pour avoir
une idée exacte toutes les recherches
que je lis toutes les recherches que je
fais m'amène aux mains dans la même
direction il faut conserver la
biodiversité ça on a cherché longtemps
pourquoi on devait conserver la
biodiversité des biologistes sont
beaucoup posé cette question là mais là
on se rend compte que plus un écosystème
est diversifié plus les résilients plus
les capables de résister à toutes sortes
de stress récupérer à toutes sortes de
stress
mon grand plaisir c'est cette relation
dans le temps il y a des armes par
exemple des érables qui sont trop petits
parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait un diamètre
une dimension suffisante pour être
entaillée peut-être c'est pour moi qui
les entaillerai peut-être qu'on les
entailler seulement dans 15 ans dans 20
ans mais il y a cette idée là que il y a
une durée on s'installe dans la durée il
y a quelque chose de magnifique là dans
cette installation c'est enracinement
dans le paysage il y a rablière c'est
éternel si on s'en occupe et c'est ça
qui est merveilleux
j'espère que Pierre bouille au bois
quand même quand on chauffe au bois ça
demande une attention particulière c'est
pour ça qu'on a choisi un système au
propane
quelle horreur ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que contrairement à d'autres
essaisiculteurs amateurs je ne suis pas
à la retraite si les pannes se vide
elles peuvent brûler elles peuvent se
déformer
le son il fait du sirop de